thank you everyone for such a warm
welcome
what an incredible room and what an
honor it is to be here today to salute
the nominees for the 95th Oscars come on
give it up
wait a minute
y'all can do better than that give it up
for the 95th Oscar nominee
thank you
yeah like everyone in this Ballroom I am
a fan of Cinema from day one and I
definitely understand the privilege we
have to do this work that we all love so
deeply along with the joy that comes
with movie making uh because being a
member of the academy and serving as a
governor makes moments like these even
that much more special a shout out to
all the governors in the house yeah
[Applause]
all right so before we begin our roll
call I have a few directions to share so
to all the nominees when your name is
called one of our event managers will
greet you at your table then guide you
toward the stage our stage managers are
also standing by to assist you once
everyone is on stage our photographer
will take over and make sure that
everybody's angles are just right so
don't worry
you gonna get your picture I promise
everybody gonna see your face I promise
you that so I have one question nominees
are you ready
all right here we go
Jamie Lee Curtis
Chris
yes yes as you hear your name please
make your way
to the stands over to the left my left
Jamie Lee Curtis actress in a supporting
role everything everywhere all at once
Ryan coogler original song Lift Me Up
from Black Panther wakanda forever
[Applause]
Mark Coulier makeup and hair styling
Elvis
Dede Gardner best picture women talking
kazuo ishiguro
adapted screenplay living
Gail Berman best picture Elvis
Ruth Carter costume design black panther
wakanda forever
come on
Brendan Fraser actor in a leading role
the whale
Shirley kurata costume design everything
everywhere all at once
Mandy Walker cinematography Elvis
from Sun Lux Ian Chang original song
everything everywhere all at once
Martin McDonough best picture directing
and original screenplay the Banshees of
any Sharon
Melanie Miller documentary feature films
navalny
Sarah Polly adapted screenplay women
talking
Rebecca Cruzan live action short film
IFA Lou
Jerry Bruckheimer best picture top gun
Maverick
Stephanie shu
actress in a supporting role everything
everywhere all at once thank you
Ryan Johnson adaptive screenplay Glass
Onion a Knives Out mystery
Diane Warren original song Applause from
Tell It Like a Woman
Jeffrey Bauman visual effects Black
Panther wakanda forever
from son Lux Rafiq Bhatia original song
original score everything everywhere all
at once
Brian Tyree Henry actor in a supporting
role Causeway
Elizabeth Holm animated feature film
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
Kate blanchetti actress in a leading
role tar
Vanessa Cole production design Avatar
the way of water
David Ellison best picture top gun
Maverick
Michael Hedges sound Avatar the way of
water
Tony Kushner best picture and original
screenplay the Fable men's
[Applause]
Stuart Wilson sound the Batman
Tom Barkley live action short film and
Irish goodbye
Anthony carlino production design
Babylon
Matthew Freud animated short film the
boy the mole The Fox and the horse
[Applause]
John Landau best picture Avatar the way
of water
Justin marks adapted screenplay top gun
Maverick
Florencia Martin production design
Babylon
Reuben oslin directing an original
screenplay triangle of sadness
Wayne patchley sound Elvis
all right
Michelle yo actress and a leading role
everything everywhere all at once
Yoni Goliad documentary feature film all
the Beauty and the bloodshed
Joel Harlow makeup and hair styling
black panther wakanda forever
Ben Proctor production design Avatar the
way of water
Mark Swift animated feature film Puss in
Boots The Last Wish
Ryan tuthold visual effects top gun
Maverick
Scott Lambert best picture car
Beth levison documentary short film The
Martha Mitchell effect
Victor Miller visual effects All Quiet
on the Western Front
all right
Jonathan Redmond film editing Elvis
Mark Weingarten sound top gun Maverick
Dean Fleischer Camp animated film
feature film Marcel the Shell with Shoes
On
Colin Farrell actor in a leading role
the Banshees of any Sharon
Al Nelson sound top gun Maverick
foreign Odessa Ray documentary feature
film navalny
Virginia
documentary short film haul out
Maxim arbugayo documentary short film
haul out
Mike Fontaine makeup and hair styling
the Batman
Simon Lorraine Wilmont documentary
feature film a house made of splinters
Cyrus neshvod live action short film The
Red suitcase
Rick Carter production design the
fablemans
Aina fitchman documentary feature film
fire of love
Brian litson visual effects top gun
Maverick
Mike Marino makeup and hair styling the
Batman
[Applause]
Michael E G Nilsson film editing the
Banshees of any Sharon
foreign
Carrie Condon actress in a supporting
role the Banshees of any sharing
Howard gertler documentary feature film
all the Beauty and the bloodshed
Caroline Kaplan animated feature film
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
Wendy tilby animated short film The
Flying sailor
Diane Becker documentary feature film
navalny
Folker bertoman original score All Quiet
on the Western Front
Peter Craig adapted screenplay top gun
Maverick
Andrew Goldman animated feature film
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
Julian Howard sound Avatar the way of
water
Lindsay Collins animated feature film
turning red
[Applause]
Connell Jones
documentary short film stranger at the
gate
Karen O'Hara
production design the fablemans
Russell Earl visual effects the Batman
James friend cinematography All Quiet on
the Western Front
Mark Gustafson animated feature film
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio
Monica hellstrom documentary feature
film a house made of splinters
gauta lead Larson live-action short film
night ride
Daniel Roar documentary feature film
navalny
Dan sudik visual effects Black Panther
wakanda forever
Gary Unger animated feature film
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio
Jonathan Wong best picture everything
everywhere all at once
[Applause]
Daniel Barrett visual effects Avatar the
way of water
Todd field best picture directing an
original screenplay tar
okay
Sarah gunars dotier animated short film
my year of dicks
[Applause]
Leslie Patterson adapted screenplay All
Quiet on the Western Front
dick Bernstein sound Avatar the way of
water
[Applause]
[Music]
Scott R Fisher visual effects top gun
Maverick
[Applause]
kartiki gonsalves documentary short film
The Elephant Whisperers
Paul Rogers film editing everything
everywhere all at once
[Applause]
column berade director of Ireland's
nominee for international feature film
the quiet girl
Dan lemon visual effects the Batman
Douglas Murray sound the Batman
Ross White
live-action short film and Irish goodbye
Carter Burrell original score the
Banshees of any Sharon
[Applause]
original song not two not two from r r r
Santiago Mitre director of Argentina's
nominee for international feature film
Argentina 1985.
Ian stokel adaptive screenplay All Quiet
on the Western Front
hika Merkur makeup and hair styling All
Quiet on the Western Front
Laura poitras documentary feature film
all the Beauty and the bloodshed
Pamela ribbon animated short film my
year of dicks
Aaron Warren singer adapted screenplay
top gun Maverick
Jason Baird makeup and hair styling
Elvis
Chris burden sound top gun Maverick
Craig hammock visual effects Black
Panther wakanda forever
Teddy Leifer documentary feature film
all that breathes
James H Mather sound top gun Maverick
Jed slanger animated feature film The
Sea Beast
Anders langlands visual effects the
Batman
Christopher macquarrie best picture and
adaptive screenplay top gun Maverick
Paul Mize animated feature film Marcel
the Shell with Shoes On
Adrian Moreau makeup and hair styling
the whale
Dylan Cole production design Avatar the
way of water
Ludwig Goranson original song Lift Me Up
from Black Panther wakanda forever
Charlie McAfee
animated short film the boy the mole The
Fox and the horse
[Applause]
Daniel sheinert best picture directing
and original screenplay everything
everywhere all at once
[Applause]
gomi she animated feature film turning
red
Edward Berger adapted screenplay and
director of Germany's nominee for
international feature film All Quiet on
the Western Front
Austin Butler
actor in a leading role Elvis
[Applause]
Alicia
live-action short film Le pupile
R Christopher white visual effects Black
Panther wakanda forever
William files sound the Batman
Justin hurwitz original score Babylon
thank you
Christy mccosko Krieger best picture the
fablemans
Frank petzold visual effects All Quiet
on the Western Front
he we Quan
role ever everything everywhere all at
once
Richard Bynum visual effects Avatar the
way of water
and Marie Bradley makeup and hair
styling the whale
documentary short film The Elephant
Whisperers
Marcus chatimler sound All Quiet on the
Western Front
Mary zafriz costume design Babylon
Joel Crawford animated feature film Puss
in Boots The Last Wish
Camille friend makeup and hair styling
black panther wakanda forever
Michael Keller sound Elvis
[Applause]
from son Lux Ryan Lott original score
and original song this is a light from
everything everywhere all at once
Aman Man Documentary feature film all
that breeds
John Lyons documentary feature film all
the Beauty and the bloodshed
Patrick McCormick best picture Elvis all
right
Gary Summers sound Avatar the way of
water
Dominic Tui visual effects the Batman
[Applause]
Chris Williams animated feature film The
Sea Beast
[Applause]
Alex Buckley animated feature film
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio
Bruno caetano animated short film ice
merchants
Malta pruners best picture All Quiet on
the Western Front
Eric sandon visual effects Avatar the
way of water
Anders Walter live action short film IFA
Lou
shindra Bose original song not too Natsu
from r r r
Judd Hirsch actor in a supporting role
the fablements
Eric toviton live-action short film
night ride
Gwendolyn Yates widdle sound Avatar the
way of water
Alfonso Faron
live action short film
[Applause]
Lucas don't
director of Belgium's nominee for
international feature film close
joao Gonzalez animated short film ice
merchants
Joshua seftel documentary short film
stranger at the gate
and Oliver gay documentary short film
The Martha Mitchell effect
Amanda forbis animated short film The
Flying sailor
Eddie Hamilton film editing top gun
Maverick
should not send documentary Beach film
feature film all that breeds
[Applause]
Brendan Gleason actor in a supporting
role the Banshees of any sharing
Aaron Krueger adapted screenplay top gun
Maverick
boss Lerman best picture Elvis
[Applause]
Catherine Martin best picture costume
design and production design Elvis
Judy Chen makeup and hair styling the
whale
Nan golden documentary feature film all
the Beauty and the bloodshed
Eric himendorf best picture triangle of
sadness
Paul meskel actor in a leading role
after sun
Shane Boris documentary feature film
fire of love and navalny
Hong Chow actress in a supporting role
the whale
Naomi Don makeup and hair styling the
Batman
Jay rosenblatt documentary short film
how do you measure a year
Tom Cruise best picture top gun Maverick
Roger deakins cinematography Empire of
light
Daniel Quan best picture directing and
original screenplay everything
everywhere all at once
Joe La Terry visual effects Avatar the
way of water
Michelle Williams actress in a leading
role the fablemans
Sarah Dosa documentary feature film fire
of love
Seth Hill visual effects top gun
Maverick
Alexandra militian best picture tar
Andy Nelson sound the Batman and Elvis
Bill Nye actor in a leading role living
Angela Bassett actress in a supporting
role black panther wakanda forever
yeah
Karen Murphy production design Elvis
Steven Spielberg best picture directing
an original screenplay the fablemans
Jersey skolimovsky director of Poland's
nominee for international feature film
EO
and last but not least Guillermo del
Toro animated feature film Guillermo del
Toros Pinocchio
all right
would you just please stand and give it
up
for this is the Academy Awards class of
2023.
congratulations to all of our nominees
[Applause]
all right okay now now here's what I
need I need everybody in the audience to
go ahead and sit down that you got your
pictures
go ahead and sit down now that you have
your pictures thank you anybody missing
a picture just get your phone out real
quick all right so everybody in place
all the nominees are in place
okay so for the nominees I need you to
please remove your name tag
we don't want to mess up the picture
and if you see your nominee next to you
with the name tag you go ahead and help
them take it off
all right cool all right so here's what
we're going to do we're going to take
five pictures in a row
five so now I want you to look up and
you're going to see the red lights and
that's where the camera is
all right everybody see the red light
all right cool so once you see the red
light I want you to start smiling are
you ready
here we go I'm gonna do a countdown
three
two one
that's the first one we're gonna do four
more all right I'm gonna count you down
again
three two one
all right we got three more
no no you calling you got it Colin we
know you got more than that all right
three two one
all right two more three two one
and here's the last one make it the best
one
[Applause]
yes all right
as our nominees make their way back to
their seats can you please stand and
give them one more incredible Round of
Applause
yes